[Applaudissements]
comme il a un petit bowser oui on va
expliquer pourquoi mon temps oui parce
que j'ai si tu le sais pas je perds tu
me le dise voilà une autre séquence non
vous savez chez thierry ardisson je fais
je pose les questions trop con que
thierry ardisson n'a pas voulu poser et
là on se concerter avec cyril et du coup
j'ai écrit les questions que cyril ne
voudrais pas vous posez donc il ya plein
de questions sur tout le monde c'est pas
pour dire mais tom et ça c'est vrai tam
est un ami ah oui ah oui ne sera pas le
week-end ensemble
vous avez parfois biaisé
c'est bien on doit alors j'ai une
première question est celle maire michel
il ya beaucoup de rumeurs qui traînent
sur internet c'est vrai que jean michel
maire en thaïlande ya une mst qui porte
votre nom
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la clarification pour daniel vous êtes
célibataire on en parle vous vivez chez
votre maman vous aimez les hommes plus
vieux et vous bossez danse est au
programme
ça fait pas beaucoup de handicaps d'un
coup qu'on pouvait m
ouais ça n'arrivera pas sur m6 avec
leurs beats leurs couteaux alors tout
seul maintenant à c'est à dire un truc
je savais qu'il fallait qu'on arrête
justement c'est pour rebondir par
rapport à jean michel maire jean-michel
je crois que vous avez été correspondant
de guerre en bosnie à l'époque vous
partie avec votre bits et votre couteau
du coup aujourd'hui les pas le
malheureux votre couteau
[Applaudissements]